i'm rob matheson in doha the top story
on al jazeera we've got breaking news in
afghanistan buildings have been
destroyed in a deadly 5.9 earthquake
which has rocked the southeast of the
country in the early hours of wednesday
morning it happened about 44 kilometers
from the city of host near particular
province 250 people are said to have
been injured the quake could be felt in
neighboring pakistan and iran well
journalists anders live for us from
kabul what more do we know about what's
been happening ali
so as you said it was an early morning
quake and you know people as far as
kabul had felt the aftershocks they had
felt the impact of it and in pakistan
because it took place in the districts
you know places that are harder to reach
places that haven't seen a lot of
development the devastation has been
immense as you said hundreds injured
hundreds possibly killed we're seeing
reports of hundreds of houses destroyed
the government is trying to send
helicopters to aid people but you know
the the issue is that the aid economy
here has been devastated you know
afghanistan has always suffered from
floods from um landslides from
earthquakes but getting aid to people in
need has always been extremely difficult
even at a time when billions of dollars
was in the country and so many foreign
aid agencies were here now they're
trying to rely as much on local aid
agencies but those are the ones that
have felt the greatest impact from the
sanctions from the cutbacks from the
pull outs from all of those things they
will really struggle to deal with this
issue until international aid agencies
can pump in money can pump in more
support because at the moment they're
really undersourced and underfunded yeah
we're just seeing some pictures as
you're talking of the aftermath of that
and there's some of the rescue efforts
um tell us about the housing in the
building there you said that this is an
area which is prone to to earthquakes
are people able to protect their homes
unfortunately people you know build with
what materials they have so you could
have mud houses you could have brick
houses uh and obviously the poorer you
are the more uh you know simple
materials you use to build your house
you know i was saying earlier that in
2015 there was a big earthquake in kabul
and you know many high-rises had huge
like gashes on the sides because even in
the city of kabul even these expensive
high-rises were not built according to
code and then so when you're talking
about farther out in the villages
unfortunately people don't always have
you know the income they don't always
have the resources and the ability to
build proper housing and then so that's
why you see you know at least a hundred
houses if not more have already been
destroyed
tell us about the the government
response to this because it has happened
as you say in the early hours of the
morning when people are sleeping how
quickly has the government been able to
get some sort of aid there given the
fact that you were saying that the the
aid budgets are limited
right
and this is going to be a major issue
for them coming up now they have said
that they have sent helicopters and they
are sending constant updates but as you
well know responding to these sorts of
natural disasters takes a lot of
coordination and it takes a lot of
practice you know this is one of the
really first big natural disasters that
the islamic emirate will be responding
to so this will be a big show of how
much they can sort of you know organize
things on the fly and what they can do
with the resources that are available to
them at the moment because as we said
earlier you know they're asking for more
help to go to local aid agencies but
local aid agencies are the ones that
have been the most affected by you know
sort of these aid cutbacks by the
sanctions and by the by the very tight
regulations the u.n has placed on how
they distribute aid and who they
distribute them to
as as often the case when we have
situations like this the the number of
dead and injured does vary very
dramatically in the first few hours what
is the latest that you're hearing from
from there
just briefly if you could because we are
running out of time could be as
sure we're hearing it could be as high
as 255 dead and hundreds up to 500
injured so far and that's increased from
about 90 in the morning to now nearly
300 you know in in the late morning
ali thank you very much indeed that's
ali latifah talking to us from all about
the the story there